so there are two parts to the  unconscious the personal and the  collective the personal unconscious  consists of memories and emotions that  the individual has repressed  forgotten or rejected the american  psychological association describes the  collective unconscious as follows the  collective unconscious is the part of  the unconscious that according to carl  jung is common to all humankind and  contains the inherited accumulation of  primitive human experiences in the form  of ideas and images called archetypes  and manifested in myths as well as other  cultural phenomena like religion and  also in dreams it is the deepest and  least accessible part of the unconscious  mind think of it this way every person  embodies patterns of behavior that are a  consequence of collective imitation  across time and generations and most of  these patterns have their roots in myths  religions and other cultural phenomena